30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
feel on the App Store or Google Play
today's workout will be focusing on your
obliques as well as your hips to really
target and get rid of those stubborn
love handles ladies I'm sure you can
relate to this there will be a total of
three circuits ok 4 exercises for each
circuit and in each circuit we want to
end with a dynamic stretch to really
lengthen your muscles as well as to
increase your flexibility let's get
started for the first circuit you will
need 1 dumbbell I would say between 3 to
4 kilos each beginners if you don't want
to use a dumbbell that is absolutely
fine okay so we want to start the first
circuit by working on your total body so
the first exercises will be standing
crunches I want you to place both hands
just by your side and your goal is to
bring your legs up to touch up your
elbows okay so just crunching to the
sides just like this it's not about
dipping your body but rather it's about
lifting your legs alright
so 45 seconds let's go lift crunch and
this is also to warm up on your obliques
so really open your legs out to the side
and really target on lifting those legs
reaching your knee to your elbows okay
so a slight crush to the side that's it
all right good do you feel your obliques
that's right nice keep going just gently
tap on the floor
and reach good keep crunching so this is
where we really want to be focusing on
and remember to breathe throughout the
entire workout okay do not hold your
breath pace your breathing with in and
breathe out good second work out
let's grab your dumbbell all right so
it's going to be a lunch and a twist
then shut up with a pod
take a step forward right leg extend
your arms up and twist to your right
side take a step back bring the dumbbell
close to you step your left leg forward
reach out and twist okay look the
opposite side step back pushing with
through your heels twist and drive it
back
tightening your core all right twist
control tighten your core drive your leg
back again reach and twist good step it
back last leg forward twist very good so
it's all about engaging your core
muscles in order for you to find that
balance and to also really work on your
obliques your twist drive it back again
beginners you can also do this workout
without any dumbbell alright third
workout which is going to be Wood chop
let's work on our left side first again
stand sugar with the pot okay with the
toes pointed forward reach to your left
as you twist bend your knees and cross
over to your side okay so step reach
twist
good up twist and cross very nice twist
and cross and you should really feel on
your right side twist crunch it back up
twist and bending your knees keeping
your knees soft twist
good up reach twist nice keep going
twist suck those belly in twist up and
reach good you're doing well you should
also feel your right thigh is working so
this is actually a compound movement all
right twist working on your entire body
to burn the fat up good now drop the
dumbbell let's get into a hip flexor
stretch so what I want to do is get into
a pike position alright catch your
breath
this is also your active rest all right
and now step your right leg forward
open up twist
and back into a plank open up twist for
your hip flexor into a plank
step back up twist good reach as high as
you can open up the sides twist
alright good now what I want to do is
step forward reach up and really feel on
your left hip flexor right reach up and
again tap down back into a plank left
reach up to your right hip flexor being
stretched out back down into a plank
step right
reach up focusing on your left side back
into a plank and just rest it up alright
now let's get back out we want to repeat
the entire circuit once more okay so the
first workout is going to be extending
crunch again with all the workouts then
sugar with a pot and let's go crush to
your side left and right poop without as
you crunch up remember aim to bring your
knee as high as you can
if this is too much then that's okay
alright just crunch a little bit bring
it back down to crush a little bit and
bring it back down
as you progress aim to lift it higher
right this has a lot to do with your
flexibility as well hence that is why I
want to end each circuit with a dynamic
stretch good keep going crunch it
tighten your core crunch let's speed it
up slightly keep going
nice last five seconds crunch it up and
we want to get straight into the next
workout which is going to be lunch and
twist so choose your option with or
without a dumbbell alright so stents
sugar with a pod step back remember to
take a wipe step forward all right step
forward reach out and twist good bring
it in step forward the other leg and
twist good you should also feel on your
shoulders
very good
strong upper body strong core an imp to
bring your knees as close to the floor
as possible and in back down twist good
look at your dumbbell if that helps with
your balance all right look
twist and step forward twist good few
more you're always there and bring it
forward squeeze it last one on the left
side and right take a break Wood chop ok
so now we want to work on the right side
so rich your dumbbell on the right side
as you crunch down chop it to the left
side ok so just working on one side
let's go reach up crunch to the side up
point your right left toes and reach up
on your right side good left toes
pointed up chop feel your left oblique
good reach up tweet as much as you can
up and just follow your dumbbell all
right up and twist good keep going twist
it up twist very good you should also
feel your heart rate increasing up and
down last few more give me two more all
right plus one more and good dynamic
stretch all right drop the dumbbell
let's get straight into a plank ok
all right nice strong plank let's just
stay here for another three seconds and
we want to reach your right leg forward
twist open up back into a plank step
left leg twist
whew your glutes your hip flexors as
well as the side of your body being
stretched up step back left leg twist
good step back and now as we step
forward reach both arms up your left hip
flexor both arms down left leg up and
pumps between your legs
step out reach up again good pumps
between your legs step back left side up
and reach down and into a plank very
good ok so that is the end of your first
circuit we want to get it we want to go
for a shot one-minute break right now ok
so catch your breath keep yourself
hydrated wipe your sweat and for the
second and third circuit you will not
need any dumbbell ok you will just need
your mat that's it alright so keep
yourself hydrated
okay right this second circuit it's
going to be challenging you on your
plank three exercises all focusing on
planks okay so the first workout I'll
just run you through the workouts the
first workout is going to be a plank
cross okay the second workout is going
to be a plank twist
all right and the final workout is going
to be a plank dip so down and up okay
two seconds let's get into a plank and
let's go plank cross so right leg
crossing over trying to reach for your
left elbow
okay so right knee to left elbow left
knee to your right elbow don't rush the
workout take your time really twist and
feel your core muscles working and your
obliques as well okay as you know plank
workouts are not the easiest it's going
to also challenge you on your upper body
so just stay focus and keep twisting
good keep going breathe in and breathe
out I can start to see my sweat dripping
let's go and now just drop it take a 15
seconds rest and plank twist okay so
again get into a plank position strong
plank if you want to spread your fingers
apart to give you a better base twist
open up to your left side and now the
other side
twist and open up to your right side
okay so we're alternating between left
and right
twist good back into a play twist
try not to sway your body too much okay
it should be in one straight line move
your hips tilt it to the left and back
down and to the right
keep going left and right left and right
very good remember to lift your hips up
okay do not let it drop lift it up twist
and keep going good
all right now plank dip okay
so let's start on our right side so get
them to your right elbow you can either
choose to stack both feet together or
you can place one fit in in front of you
all right
so go down lift it up down and lift it
up choose your option okay up and down
so control the movement do not rush
through the workout and lift it up
really feel the squeeze on your right
oblique lift it up if you want to it's
like both feet up and just look straight
ahead up it's a really small movement
but it's really effective okay if you're
feeling good take the next step bring
your head up and just lift find your
balance tighten your core and lift it up
feel your hips working as well last few
more up that's one more up and just rest
it out dynamic stretch so it's going to
be a Cobra to downward dog alright so
let's start in a plank position okay
we're gonna flow through this stretch
okay so into a Cobra stretch your lower
back out and then straight into downward
dog
alright so really feel the stretch on
your legs your thighs your hamstrings
and back into a plank and transit into a
Cobra look up feel your lower back being
stretched out and into downward dog good
so look between your legs through your
lower back being stretched out and again
Cobra and just take this time to breathe
and back down whoo within
and out and just flow very good okay
that's your cue for the second round of
this circuit okay
first workout plank twists alright I am
sweating and you should be sweating as
well okay let's get into a plank
position and let's twist right knee to
left elbow left knee to right elbow keep
going
twist reach as far as you can alright
try to bring your knee as close to your
elbow as possible breathe in and breathe
out good huh you are strong kay keep
your core strong you are strong every
movement every sweat is your effort
it's your fat-burning pace your
breathing you have only less than five
seconds left
breathe in breathe out and okay well
sweaty plank twist okay so get back into
a plank position and we want to twist to
your left and right okay ready in three
two one
and let's go twist reach up strong
shoulders twist back down okay
do not just collapse down control the
movement
reach up stay here for two seconds back
down lift your hips up stay here for
another two seconds and come back down
all right look to it your fingers good
reach and back it down and again down
you have few more to go give me two more
on each side okay down strong pike do
not drop right now you're over there one
more on each side
left and down good okay we have worked
on the left side now let's work on the
right side so get onto your left elbow
okay and stack your feet either together
or one forward choose your option okay
let's go up hang on to your waist and
dip up and down okay good you should
feel your left obliques working up and
down up and down
whoo keep pushing push your elbows into
the floor right to find your balance
again if you want to challenge yourself
raise up look straight up dip and look
up alright I'll look forward up and down
up and down
good remember to keep your body in a
straight line
small but really effective movement whoo
my right side my left side is burning
okay right final dynamic stretch before
you get another one-minute break
oh my god if you can see me right now I
am drenched in sweat let's go let's get
into a plank let's get into Cobra look
up stretch out and into downward dog try
to bring your heels to the floor it's
not just tiptoe if you're struggling
back into plank into Cobra weave in and
downward dog again hold this pose for
two to three seconds push into the
ground feel your lower back and the
hamstrings being stretched out and Cobra
and into downward dog try to bring your
heels close to the floor each time you
get into that pose okay again push in
and now just get into a child's pose
very very well done that's two seconds
down okay so one minute break keep
yourself hydrated and we want to end at
the final circuit with lots of crunches
grab yourself a drink okay
find a circuit again we don't need any
weights just a mat and yourself okay so
let me run you through some of the
workouts the first workout is going to
be air bike so again you can choose your
option you can either place both feet on
the ground okay and both hands just by
the side of your head what I want to do
is twist and reach okay that's it so
twist and reach twist and reach okay if
you find this too easy what you can do
is lift both legs off the floor and then
twist and reach okay so choose your
option all right so ready let's go down
twist and reach beginners you can start
here all right and as you progress you
can always lift both legs off the floor
keep going and now a little bit more
challenge let's go and lift both legs
off the floor you should find it a
little bit more challenging right now
because we have done two seconds okay
off why no balance look straight ahead
twist and reach good twisting reach
again place both legs down if you want
to and reach good
keep going whoo ten more seconds twist
and reach keep going last few more oh my
legs are sore and last one more and
press it out okay so the next one is
going to be a cross tuck I want you to
place both palms on the floor what I
want to do is if you can't grab your
dumbbell
place it in the middle I want you to
cross both feet over okay so cross talk
one in cross over tuck it in and cross
over and tuck it in okay so place
something on the floor just as an
indicator tuck it in cross over
tuck nice cross tuck good nice and
controlled okay cross over keep going I
feel the burn as well nice cross talk
last few more cross tuck one more last
one
tuck and give me on the other side tuck
and drop it all right put your dumbbell
aside and final workout is going to be
crap to attach okay so what you need to
is bring your heels closer to your body
lift your body up okay and now reach the
opposite side okay so it's like a
reverse plank position reach and control
nice and control do not rush the workout
if you rush through trust me you're just
gonna stumble okay reach oops that's
what I meant
and reach lift your hips up squeeze
crossover move your hips okay this is
all about moving your hips and crunching
on your obliques good move your hips
lift it up tap and reach okay if this is
difficult just tap on your shin to begin
with as you progress try to go for your
toes reach and drop it okay find a
stretch it's going to be a bird dog
stretch so get into all fours alright
again here's a tip if you want to find
your balance
spread your fingers apart that will give
you a better foundation okay let's go
stretch it opposite side bring it back
down nice and easy okay
no fast or difficult movements stretch
it back down rich I want to lengthen and
feel your back being stretched out line
squeeze her glutes back down squeeze and
just gently gaze on the floor keep your
neck neutral do not look forward and
strain your neck all right
so gaze gently on the floor reach and
back it down very good and this is also
your active rest and we want to repeat
the entire circuit one more time rich
back down rich and back down good 15
seconds to rest okay
add bikes all right let's go again hands
on the side of your head both heels down
onto the floor and cross over okay cross
drive your knee towards your elbow the
opposite side all right good crunch it
and take your time to just feel the
squeeze squeeze one count release good
so really squeeze and hold on one count
and release do not just haha
this is rawhide so just find your base
squeeze and release crunch through and
release it's all about making each rep
count good squeeze and release aim to
have your back flat as much as possible
squeeze that release tighten your core
squeeze and release good last two more
last one more and ha okay choose your
option you can either place an object in
the middle just as an indicator and
again pumps on the floor fingers points
it forward
start on your left side and we want to
tuck and cross okay tuck crossover tuck
crossover and tuck your arms are just
supporting you
it should be your apps doing all the
work talk and cross nice tuck and cross
whew feel that burn really feel that
burn drive your chest to your knee
halfway there good do that burn chest
uni
if you need to rest for a while
crossover tuck drop it rest for a while
crossover and talk okay
last one this is a final second let's
not stop right now
and drop it good
put your weight aside crap toe touch
okay
so again bring your heels closer to your
body lift yourself up start in this high
reverse plank position okay as you find
your balance reach and tap reach and tap
okay so lift your hips up and reach for
your toes you can always keep your knees
bent reach and tap reach and tap good
strong upper body as well okay good keep
going only 45 seconds tap and control
the movement back down as well
breathe in and breathe out
nice almost there
and we have one final dynamic stretch
reach and tap tap and good alright now
let's get onto all fours your favorite
part of the workout okay take a moment
to breathe in flatten your back and
ready let's go right hand up left leg up
squeeze lengthen your back bring it back
down lengthen and back down again
remember to keep your neck neutral and
gently gaze on to the floor
good reach
find your balance tighten your core keep
your back flat and reach okay rich
squeeze your glutes lengthen it's all
about lengthening imagine the string
pulling you at the front and at the back
point your toes lengthen back down
release last few more lengthen and rest
it out all right I just want you to get
into a child's pose and just breathe and
slow your heart rate down
and now just reach your right hand
underneath your left and just twist and
feel the stretch on your back okay so
it's just just some gentle stretches to
end your workout and I'll change side
reach
in and now get into a Cobra just to
stretch your abs and your lower back
we've done a lot of work on your lower
back as well as your core so just
stretch it out and remember do not dip
into your shoulders okay push your
shoulders away from your neck and feel
the stretch again now let's reach
towards the left side just really feel
the stretch on your right obliques
stretch and now let's go on to the right
side and feel the stretch on your left
obliques pushing your shoulders away
from your neck okay and you are done I
hope you're sweating and that your core
is on fire they give this workout a
thumbs-up share this workout with your
girlfriends and keep doing this workout
consistently
combine this workout with my total body
strength training as well as cardio
workout and you will start to notice
your love handles disappear don't forget
to also check out my recipe videos as
well as nutritional tips video on my
workout channel and hit the subscribe
button if you haven't yet done it and
also remember to turn on your
notification button so that you will be
the first to get notified every time I
share a new video all the best